your last appearance I'm worried because
I'm afraid that I got you in trouble you
were on the show and you said something
about the princes the in England yes and
you said something that I guess got you
in trouble in the United Kingdom in
England is that right
yeah well I didn't know that your show
such a huge hit over there I mean it's a
big deal this show did you know that
because you like big so you thought you
were speaking anonymously why don't you
repeat what it is you said about Harry
and William okay so I met him at this
polo match and I I met them and I had
said to you that you said what are they
what did they I want to talk about and I
said all they wanted to know was about
the friends reunion yeah and he said
what'd you tell him and I said well I
told clearly clearly kidding you didn't
really say that to them you were kidding
no but apparently that got picked up in
people saw that you say that in England
and so you went over there to do press
for episodes and and the press was like
first question every like it was ten
days in a row of interviews all day long
to launch the show and everyone asked so
why did you tell the principal yeah yeah
why did you why would you say that yeah
yeah I was like it was a joke I never
said that right good right there a
bigger than me right and be that it
would it be rude that would be rude yeah
yeah
so maybe now since clearly everyone in
England is watching you'd like to smoke
you like to say now about Harry and
William well thank you I would like to
say that they are very handsome
[Applause]
yes situation clear it up fine now takes
a little proper anything I can do for
you yeah hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please